france label dont trois bons sens dan
bigras bonsoir à tous on est ici fameux
refuge 25 que ce show là existe 25 ans
du refuge
les besoins pas là mais rebelles sont
tous y en a pas on est loin d'avoir
réglé
c'est un problème qui se réglera jamais
vraiment mais pour pouvoir régler la
question de l'itinérance faudrait régler
la question de la pauvreté qu'il
faudrait arrêter de produire les tenir
sous d'intervenir en amont avant que les
gens arrivent dans la rue moi je dis
l'itinérant ça se prépare ça arrive
rarement du jour au lendemain qu'on
connaît mieux les facteurs même si c'est
pas simple non plus mais on n'est pas en
voie de régler mais on est en voie ont
contribué à améliorer par exemple soit
c'est très très important et ce grand
monsieur laak qui participent au show du
refuge grâce à lui grâce à tous ces
artistes là grâce à la population qui
vont qui donne vous c'est le quart de
votre budget ne s'est pas pressé c'est
pas un petit peu de crème âge là c'est
essentiel oui ça fait partie du caire du
refuge parce que sur 1 billion sur un
budget d'un million c'est un car c'est
très important ça nous permet aussi
parlé des teens errance d'expliquer ce
qui se passe ça permet de faire
connaître le refuge aussi que l'endroit
où les jeunes peuvent venir coucher en
sécurité à montréal
c'est la moindre des choses qu'on peut
faire exactement faudra toujours
strictement
oui et même à se prêter à toutes et tous
les soirs ça être plein à capacité là
vous vous êtes vous avez des besoins
énormes ça cogne à la porte et aujourd
hui nous séjour sur jour soir nuit un
don qu'elle soit l'accueil d'urgence
c'est important montréal où c'est
d'avoir un hub d'urgence puis quand on
parle d'urgence on parle de la base qui
on parle aussi même de soins de soins de
santé essentiels
on parle aussi ça c'est le site refuge
m'ont aussi des logements sociaux
donc pour des jeunes qui à un moment ou
un autre
veulent connaître une stabilité alors
donc le spectre est très très très large
dans le processus des jeunes dans leur
processus de villes souvent ici encore
refuge c'est la partie la plus pauvre
qu'il est de l'or vous dit
tant mieux si ça permet de les débuts de
retour exactement je retourne je tiens
de ma tante trouve sa vie en vaut pas la
peine que jamais clair la question qui
se pose tous pourquoi personne même pas
la réponse de tomates s'expose end et
rémi loup jean d'amour et sur scène par
tang c'est la préparation d'accords
s'est effectué la jeune qui a fait deux
semaines qu'il est encore pire et il
s'adapte comme s'ils voulaient mourir
madani se pose une question maintenant
c'est seulement si je meurs tu sais où
je vais demander de l'aide
il décide de demander de line on
s'arrache tous quelqu'un derrière la
porte s'est tenue parce que c'est là le
début du retour elle peut avoir plein de
rechute plein de plans catastrophe mais
les jeunes que je peux le dire ici font
jamais petit monsieur c'est dur de les
voir en a lâché mais c'est la résilience
un carnet de la gagne peuvent ils
peuvent se disent qu'ils vainquent fois
21e ça va être la bonne puisque l'on
retrouve des monsieurs tournage bien
habillés qui me présente
enfin ça ça m'arrive de fou aisément
parce que beaucoup parce qu'ils ont eu
des déposes parce qu'ils ont eu des gens
qui les ont gardées justement qui ont
indiqué ce qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pour t'aider qu'ils on s en sort accueil
reconnu connu il y en a qui vont
maintenant ça va être le refuge où être
leur base parce qu'ils vont pouvoir
venir parler à des gens justement qui
vont les appeler par leur nom
et puis la question de la solitude où
c'est très très très importante la
détresse est très élevé des fois elle
est vraiment absolue d'autres fois c'est
un coup dur de la vie l'info intervenir
rapidement
il faut pas attendre que le jeune se
découragent décourager pic perdre tous
ses repères autour de lui on a beaucoup
parlé de la période d'austérité au
québec que des chevaux fédéral aussi que
vous jugez vous votre budget pour le
québec ici ça a été maintenu mais le
fédéral nous a coupé vos appartements
suis amusé à l'instar d'autres
organisent comme notamment on a eu sur
les subventions fédérales 55% de couper
on parle de logements pour des gens qui
ont connu la rue donc c'est inacceptable
de couper dans des dents dans la base
est là au moment où ça commence à s'en
sortir
au moment où ce qui commence à s'en
sortir on me rappelle quand il apprit
zone est beaucoup pour des disquettes le
jeune sprint ce qui est juste pour ça
qu'à 6 6 3 puis c'est vraiment un
soulagement du raffut ça allait mieux et
venu jobs langues commencent à s'en
sortir
de res police n'a cherché sa crain
prison voit aussi le convainquit a pas
de complot l'empêcher de s'en sortir
c'est la même chose qu'on coupe c'est
son élan les coupes de 1 à des gens que
sur support de s'en sortir
la pop s'avertir en arrière ça climie
vrai drame humain et deuxièmement c'est
malheureux mais il refuse puis
l'allemand sociaux sont des vases
communicants c'est le même argent petit
couple autres une copie ci est ce que le
nouveau gouvernement nous avait des
engagements où il ya des engagements de
rétablir des programmes
on a espoir mais suivre son disque on a
dit en terminant rapidement donc il
reste des biens pour mercredi soir
oui je sais bien pour meurtre et de soi
on a beaucoup de bien aux balcons ou pas
tout le temps sont moins chers quarante
pièces mais on met pas du monde en
arrière le gars du banc leur milieu
heureusement tous les trucs pour vous
mettre l'adresse sénat qui veulent
donner aussi que peuvent pas le
spectacle qui veulent pas peu importe on
peut je suis un important directement
merci beaucoup
puis bon show mercredi face à toi tu as
lu